as you look at house moment in
Wolverhampton we're going to multi let
it and so if you spin the cam around you
can see a few of the rooms so nice
simple they will ring all day long
3:50 there about early third
decent-sized room obviously barren why
there's a family living here at the
moment once of these gone big room fire
escape hey job done so how much rent
would you get from this whole house I
reckon this is about 1400 Rin so
probably own thirty thirty percent on a
return capital in order to see the 30
percent loss return on investment and
get 1400 pounds Rex you would need to
convert them into HMOs by putting fire
doors smoke alarms and fully furnishing
them which will cost around about seven
thousand pounds 70 80 thousand what
we're going to this house how we've got
another viewing in 30 minutes it
wouldn't be surprised me if we haven't
made six or seven offers and buying a
few by the end of the day what's this
place
Josh you've just had a house accepted
and you're in the process of buying a
beautiful property tell us a little bit
about the day so far so we've had -
we've actually got two options accepted
one slightly more exciting the other the
other is a full bed the one that we've
got a lot on this afternoon is a 5-bit
and if it doesn't go through we'll go
again we've seen it up the laser -
Ostrosky
we've been all over the place and also
sylveon you've what house to do as well
yes excellent up 50 you like or
fantastic we'll give Jason you ponder
why five Jason tell us the details
nice good condition very simple get in
there without competition room at the
foibles so
buzz its firmness to the town yeah
four men stood round from line just
across and how much rent in you expect
him right in three six
it's about 1,400 yeah excellent good job
man come and join the Cornish NT with me
and Joshy Hampton and being driven
around in a rather large Land Rover my
houses
josh is telling his girlfriend of the
good news
meanwhile Jason and sylveon are
following in the car behind I am back
tomorrow for a bit so before we move on
to other things it's time to view one
more house which is what you kind of get
the idea now you've seen the full bed
mid terraced houses so you've seen them
before but here's one after it's been
furnished welcome this is one that's
actually just completed and the tenants
will be moving in next week paying a
total rent of fourteen hundred pounds
per calendar month my first how it's all
going furnished very nourishing and safe
so I had half a bed and then the rest
was kind of made up the boxes that's how
I solve it so every house is specs
exactly the same as the same carpets the
same fire door the same alarm system if
necessary the furniture packs will be
brought in in bulk and set up for us so
the rooms they all look identical you'll
notice we keep referring to the rent
being 1,400 pounds this is the most
important thing that we look for when
buying a house what will it give us each
month but of course we want a bargain
- nice actually really good size not
gonna be upset living area it's not like
tiny nice furniture and superfast
broadband is crucial when watching
professionals to move in I feel like the
furniture it makes a difference yeah
it's good this is my couple will be
living in here yeah
paying around 400 pounds a month which
makes a vast difference is worth is
having the corner yeah Jimmy said does
good furnishing package yes
so again nice simple plain new furniture
3:30
daelin each one of the four bedrooms
went out for between 300 and 400 pounds
per month depending on the size of the
room offensive I thought I got you but
operating is not houses myself to living
my wife and you know these are these are
nice rooms
I'll be more than happy yeah yeah
opening this to feel a problem so you've
got these single bed Jason can't believe
with the house getting so much rent that
it was bought for only eighty six
thousand pounds how much was it 86 as
his grand for the house yeah 1350 pen
month yeah 13 Center 13 so no no brainer
I my work is here it is handmade wooden
furniture as far as plaque becos these
are nice not just a quality but just a
look with a bit of fault gone into it
color on the wall not alder same
Magnolia a bit of change of pain it
lifts overhanging is so easy to do
really easy to do you're paying the same
money for that painters what you offer
that so why not bit of color yeah works
comfort yeah awesome mattresses you ever
got cheap which is brilliant this is
really good so if you're the buyer
nature my Sam as a man to come to speak
to good job yeah Sam is the man lovely
job
we've just bought a house today oh we're
told you're the person who can manage it
yes I am that's brilliant
of course Josh is then introduced to a
local power team to make sure that
everything can now happen without him
being around the job if you want to see
us view and buy more houses in real life
like this and don't forget to like share
and subscribe and the more you do that
the more we will film if you're also
interested in investing yourself and
getting crazy high returns then don't
forget go down to WWE - investors doctor
at UK and we can help you do that too